la proporción de las dimensiones de la
tierra y la luna forman un triángulo
dorado la proporción dorada representada
por fin es el único número que tiene la
propiedad matemática de que su cuadrado
es el mismo masón hay más vídeos sobre
la proporción dorada que les darán
escalofríos si los ven y hacen este
ejercicio les darán aún más escalofríos
filmas uno es igual la fia al cuadrado
si vale 1.61 803 hasta el infinito
si esto le sumamos uno nos va a dar si
al cuadrado que es dos puntos 60 y 1 803
hasta el infinito al aplicar el teorema
de pitágoras a esta ecuación se
construye un triángulo rectángulo cuyos
lados son fin raíz cuadrada de fi y 1 lo
que quiere decir esto es que si yo hago
este un a cuadrada esto que sea b
cuadrada y esto se cuadrada podemos
pensar en esto como los lados de un
triángulo rectángulo en donde nuestra
hipotenusa c es fin y el lado más corto
es uno y el otro cateto va a ser raíz
cuadrada del fin de hecho lo voy a
dibujar aquí abajo para que se note
mejor
esto será a que es igual a raíz de fi
raíz cuadrada de fin esto será sé que es
igual a fi y esto de aquí va a ser b que
es igual a 1 a continuación se muestra
que el radio de la tierra y la luna
están en proporción a fin esto de que el
radio de la tierra y la luna están en
proporción a fin es sorprendente si
tomamos el radio de la tierra lo voy a
subrayar en otro color este radio de la
tierra y le agregamos el radio de la
luna es que acá la suma de ambos radios
o la proporción de dicha suma con
respecto al radio de la tierra este
radio de acá es raíz cuadrada de fi y
esto sí que nos hace pensar sobre el
universo vamos en el vídeo y reflexionen
sobre esto pues esto no sólo aparece
aquí sino en toda la naturaleza y en
todas las matemáticas si es un número
fascinante por muchas razones pero bueno
nos dicen si el radio de la tierra es de
6 mil 371 kilómetros cual es el radio de
la luz lo que voy a hacer ahorita es re
dibujar este triángulo en términos de
los kilómetros del radio de la tierra el
que tenemos aquí este en términos de un
radio terrestre así que voy a hacer otro
triángulo por acá voy a dibujar la
silueta de la tierra más o menos
como que por acá bueno no me está
saliendo muy bonito y vamos a dibujar
también lo que le corresponde a la luna
más o menos algo así ok nos dan el radio
de la tierra este radio de la tierra que
es de 6 mil
371 kilómetros y nos están preguntando
el radio de la luz esta distancia de acá
esta distancia le vamos a llamar r como
vamos a calcular r bueno también
conocemos este segmento de aquí este de
acá también es un radio terrestre y vale
lo mismo seis mil
371 kilómetros y esto es un triángulo
rectángulo y eso nos deja con un
problema bastante sencillo el radio
combinado podemos escribirlo como r más
nuestro radio de la tierra
6.371 asumimos que todo está en km para
no escribir esto es igual a raíz
cuadrada de fib por el radio de la
tierra este lado como tenemos aquí
expresado por un radio de la tierra esto
es raíz cuadrada de fi por este radio de
la tierra aquí este uno los reemplazando
por el 6.371 así que todo esto es igual
a este radio de la tierra
6.371 por raíz cuadrada de fi eso es lo
que hicimos al redibujar este triángulo
con respecto al radio de la tierra no
con respecto a uno entonces nos queda
que esto es igual a seis mil
371 por raíz
vamos a restar 6.371 en ambos lados nos
va a quedar que r es igual a 6 mil
371 por raíz cuadrada de fin menos 6 mil
371 y factor izamos
6.371 estos dos me va a quedar igual a 6
mil
371 por raíz cuadrada de fi menos 1 y
esto este resultado es bastante general